la bannière l'eau bla qui comprend les
épiceries Provigo et maxi fixent les
prix jusqu'au 31 janvier sur plus de
1500 produits de sa marque maison sans
nom qu'on peut reconnaître dans les
supermarchés grâce à son étiquette jaune
je trouve que c'est une bonne nouvelle
en fait je trouve que c'est un prix en
fait que tu devrais pas trop varier en
général question que c'est quand même la
marque de base on s'entend
habituellement on prend des trucs un peu
plus bio et tout ça donc ça nous a fait
qu'un peu moins on sait jamais quand on
va faire l'épicerie si le prix va
augmenter ou diminuer c'est sûr que ça
sera pas le cas alors que le prix des
aliments connaît une hausse de 9,7%
depuis l'année dernière un gel des prix
pourrait aider davantage les ménages à
s'y retrouver selon option consommateur
un geste c'est mieux que d'augmentation
on va prendre ce qu'on peut
l'impact dépend toujours
dans le fond du pouvoir d'achat des gens
oui
selon le professeur de marketing Jacques
Nantel calcule perdre un peu d'argent
sur chacun de ces produits vendus avec
la marque son nom mais espère en bout de
ligne déplacer de la clientèle verset
magasin ce que l'on vise à faire c'est
c'est de changer les comportements des
consommateurs autrement dit consommateur
si vous voulez pouvoir avoir un peu plus
d'argent dans vos poches vous allez
devoir changer vos habitudes avant
l'aube on me la chaîne de supermarché
françaises carrefour et la branche
américaine de la compagnie les Dolls ont
tous deux respectivement gelés et
baisser le prix sur une centaine de
leurs produits pour une période
déterminée et au Québec la compagnie
métro a annoncé aujourd'hui qu'elle fera
le gel sur le prix de certains produits
de marque privée et nationales du 1er
novembre au 5 février ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal